[Music]
what is this I'm sorry Kyle this is not
the way I like to do things don't do it
what do you want from me
your past Ascenta me carefully Cal
you're about to enter the Animus what
you're about to see hear and feel are
the memories of someone who's been dead
for 500 years boy a minute
synchronization achieved
commence regression
you hear to save myself
I understand it's your birthday yeah the
party's just getting started his name is
Callan Minj
we've traced his bloodline back 500
years to the Assassin's Creed Cal has
anyone in the world knows or cares you
no longer exist
[Music]
is this place
this is your second chance
[Music]
what do you want from me your past
you're about to enter the Animus what
you see hear and feel are the memories
of your ancestor he's been dead for 500
years wait a minute
welcome to the Spanish Inquisition
what I saw in there and felt real
[Music]
it was
you're watching you way to see Lee Whorf
I believe you are destined for great
things that's fine now
work in the dark turn up the lights
we are assassins
I'm beginning to like this
in terms of the fighting poverty are
these weapon of choice with the blades
on the wrists
it was very important